[Musique]
dans le peloton de la cima saron 2018 la
découverte des trois cirques n'a pas la
même saveur
les 800 participants le savent le lever
du soleil au gîte départemental du piton
des neiges est incomparable et on
découvre le choeur de l'ill à c'est
comme ça qu'on fait pour découvrir
sinon on s'entasse côté c'est soit on
sent pas tandis que l'on peut sortir ses
plaisirs
c'est un peu mal mais bon ça c'est un
petit mot pour tous ceux qui sont sur la
canapé la voilà ces canapés mais vous
vous dîtes nous si fabrice fontaine à
percer les nuages en tête c'est maxime
grenon en vacances dans l'île qui
impressionne par une foule et efficace
contre le dénivelé afin d'apprécier le
beau paysage
[Musique]
oui ma moitié
deux stratégies la fois c'est chez moi
ça fait du bien à moi mon esprit ces
atouts le puîné c'est chouette s'est
jamais fait ce parcours alors je suis
super contente première fois ces masques
abl au milieu de la forêt départementaux
domaniale depuis 24 ans cette course
fait le tour des trois cirques
une diversité qui motive
[Musique]
on se dit quoi la tête juste en bas du
mur par mur quand même ouais rien dans
la tête la ville est tranquille c'était
la bonne solution non
un réseau de 895 km de sentiers qui fait
le lien entre ces territoires
une gestion de l'eau à nef pour le
compte du département et il goûtait en
une seule journée est un privilège même
s'il ne faut pas oublier l'essentiel la
course un plaisir là des moments où les
mots là des moments où les barrières à
des beaumont où les difficultés et de
vrais combattants y revient
[Musique]
tout cela et tout le reste vous pourrez
le retrouver dans le prochain terre de
trail
[Musique]